donc là vous voyez la parcelle sur
laquelle j'ai déposé un permis de
construire
résidente à coignières depuis 41 ans
christine amaury souhaite construire
cette maison
problème la mairie d'auch coignard a
rendu un sursis à statuer sur cette
demande
en clair la municipalité se donne le
droit de décider ultérieurement
de leur côté l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et le préfet ont
donné un avis favorable
j'ai acheté ce terrain que je dois
aujourd'hui j'ai un prêt sur de
nombreuses années je vais l'acheter
constructibles et le paie lui laurent
inconstructibles conseillère municipale
opposés au plan local d'urbanisme
christina mort et a été contrainte de
quitter la majorité communale le pmu
compétence de la ville déterminent
l'évolution de la ville le quartier du
pont de chevreuse est concerné par cette
planification
l'objectif du pays et lui est de rendre
inconstructibles l'intérieur des terol
en coeur d'îlot en fait donc c'est ce
qu'on vend en pointillés tout ça ça
reste un bon truc tible les opposants se
sont organisés en association des
riverains du pont de chevreuse face à la
contestation la mairie se défend sur les
orientations du plan local d'urbanisme
c'est un plan local d'urbanisme qui a
notamment pour orientation d'autres
orientations bien sûr mais notamment
comme orientation de mettre en valeur
l'environnement est également de
conserver la qualité du cadre de vie de
la ville de coignières nous souhaitons
conserver sur ce quartier plus
particulièrement du pan de chevreuse une
qualité de vie c'est un quartier qui est
peu dense et je pense qu'il faut
conserver cette qualité de vie ce projet
a été arrêté lors du dernier conseil
municipal le 19 décembre dernier
de son côté christine à mort et a lancé
une procédure contentieuse devant le
tribunal administratif contre la
décision de la commune